I wanted to talk a little bit more about
deep learning and some of a kind of
slightly more large and interesting
architectures that have been coming
along in the last couple of years last
few years so just a very brief recap
right we've got videos on this I'm going
to draw my network from the top down
this time so rather than there being a
square input image I'm just going to
draw a line which is the image from the
top and so you can work with your
animation magic and sort this all out
for me brilliant so I'm going to be
talking about deep learning and
convolutional neural networks so a
convolutional neural network is one
where you have some input like an image
you filter it using a convolution
operation and when you repeat that
process a number of times to learn
something interesting about that image
some interesting features and then you
make a classification decision based on
it that is usually what you do right so
you might decide what this we've got a
cat in it or this one's got a dog in it
or this one's got a cat and a dog in it
and that's very exciting so from the top
down right because everyone's gonna run
out of ink if I start trying over too
many boxes you've got an input image but
it's quite large usually so that here's
an input image and I'm gonna draw it
like this this is from the top so if
this is my image I'm gonna go to the top
and look at it straight down which I
realized sort of like that does that
work
now there's three input channels because
of course we had usually red green and
blue right so in some sense this is
multi-dimensional we're gonna have our
little filtering so I'm going to draw a
couple of kernels let's maybe draw four
we're gonna do a convolution operation
using this one on here so it's going to
look over all of these three channels
it's going to scan along and it's going
to calculate some kind of features like
an edge or something like this and
that's going to produce another feature
right and now there's four kernels of
each gonna do this so we're gonna have
four outputs don't worry I'm not going
to do an 800 layer deep network this way
so each of these gets to look at all of
the three something that's a bit a bit
of a sort of quirk of deep learning but
maybe isn't explained often enough but
actually these I'll have an extra
dimension that lets them look at these
so the next layer along will look at all
four of these ones and so on what we
also then do and I'm going to sort of
get why not why not use multiple colors
we events sometimes also spatially down
sample so we bait we said to take the
maximum we have a region of pixels so
that we can make the whole thing smaller
and fit it better on our graph
we're gonna downsample this so it's
gonna look like this and then okay I'll
just do a yellow one why not can we see
yellow on this well soon find out yeah
yeah so let's say there's two kernels
here and with condor you can kind of see
it I think we need to go pink here
pink pink pink forget yellow no yellow
on white that was what I was told when I
first started using PowerPoint like pink
no that kind yeah that can that can work
it caught it looks a bit like a red so
that's going to look at all these four
so and there's two of them so there's
going to be two outputs right just think
of in terms of four inputs to outputs so
that's going to be sort of like this I'm
just going to go back to my blue and
forget the colors now and you just
repeat this process for quite a while
right depending on the network there are
more advanced architectures like
resinates but let this become very very
deep you know hundreds of layers
sometimes but for the sake of argument
let's just say it's into the dozens
usually so we're gonna down sample a bit
more and so on and then we'll get some
kind of final feature vector hopefully a
summary of everything that's in all
these images sort of summarized for us
and that's where we do our
classification so we attach a little
neural network to this here and that all
connects to all of these and then this
is our reading of whether it's a cat or
not that's the idea the problem with
this is that these number of connections
here are fixed this is the big drawback
of this kind of network you're using
this to do this very interesting feature
calculation and then you've got this
fixed number of it's always three here
there's always one here so this always
has to be the same size which means that
this input also has to always be the
same size let's say 256 pixels by 256
pixels which is not actually very big so
what tends to happen is that we take our
image that we were interested in and we
shrink it to 256 by 256 and put that in
you know and so when we train our
network we make a decision early on as
to what kind of appropriate size we
should use now of course it doesn't
really make any sense currently because
we have lots of different kinds of sizes
image obviously they can't be too big
because we're run out of RAM but it
would be nice if we if it was a little
bit flexible the other issue is but this
is actually taking our entire image and
summarizing it in one value so all
spatial information is lost right you
can see that the spatial information is
getting lower and lower as we go through
this network to the point where all we
care about is if it's a cat not where is
the cat what if we wanted to find out
where the cat was or segment the cat
tutor or somet in a person or count a
number of people right to do that this
isn't gonna work because it always goes
down to one so that's kind of a yes or
no is yeah yeah yes or no you could have
multiple outputs if it was yes dog no
cat you know different outputs sometimes
instead of a classification you output
an actual value like the amount of
something but in this case that's not
that's not worry about it now you've
told me that this is an amazing market
so I'm gonna have a go at this I said
anyone ever raised your marker in your
videos I mean this is a first that okay
it's work he's just gonna take quite a
while because it stuck this rubber is
tiny you know what I qualities Marcus
all right there we go
all right so the same input still
produces this little feature vector but
now instead of a fixed size neural
network on the end we're just going to
put another convolution of one pixel by
one pixel so it's just a tiny little
filter but it's just one by one and
that's going to scan over here and
produce an image of exactly the same
size but this of course we'll be looking
for all of these and working out in
detail what the object is so it will
have much more information than these
ones back here so you know this could be
outputting a heat map of where the cats
are or where the dogs are or you know
the areas of disease in sort of a
medical image or something like this and
so this is called a fully convolutional
network because there are no longer any
fully connected or fixed size layers in
this network so normal deep learning in
some sense or at least up until so
2014-2015 predominantly just put a
little new network on the end of this
that was a fixed size now we don't do
that and the nice thing is if we double
the size of this input image I mean
we're using more RAM but this is going
to double little double and in the end
this will also double and we'll just get
the exact same result which is bigger so
we can now put in different size images
the way this actually works in practice
is that when one your deep learning
library like cafe 2 or pi stalks or
tensorflow
will allocate memory as required so you
put in an input image and it goes well
ok with that input image we're going to
need to allocate this much RAM to do all
this and so the nice thing is that this
can now have information on where the
objects are as well as what they are
picks
output so we'll show a few examples of
semantic segmentation on the screen so
you can see the kind of thing we're
talking about the obvious downside here
which is what I'm going to leave for
another video is that this is very very
small you know maybe this is only a few
pixels by a few pixels or something like
this or you haven't done that much down
sampling and so it's not a very deep
network and you haven't learned a whole
lot if you are looking for where is the
carrier's image you have kind of it's
down in the bottom left it would be very
very general so it would be you know bit
sort of area maybe there's something
else going on over here it depends on
the resolution of this image looks great
with different colors in line but what
are you actually using this stuff
alright so I mean we have to extend this
slightly which I'm you know normally
going to postpone for another video
because this is too small for us to be
practical right what we could do is just
up up sample this we could use linear or
bilinear interpolation to just make this
way bigger like this and have a bigger
output image and it would still be very
low resolution you'd get the rough idea
of where something was but it wouldn't
be great right so you could use this to
find objects that you're looking for so
for example in our lab we're using this
for things like analysis of plants so
where are the wheat is how many are
there that can be useful in a field to
try and work out what the yield or
disease problems are going to be you can
do it for medical images where the
tumors in this image segmenting x-ray
images we're also doing it on human pose
estimation and face estimation so you
know where is the face in this image
where are the eyes what shape is the
face this kind of thing so you can use
this for a huge amount of things but
we're going to need to extend it a
little bit more to get the best out of
it and the extension we'll call an
encoder decoder Network
are you tying it up now what are you
doing it's not neat enough this there's
little bits of unwrapped out bits bear
with me I start on the next video in a
minute yeah that's as good as it's
getting it